what's happening there reject nation
we're going to watch today from gom
films chris evans reaction
sam new captain america dub i'm really
looking forward to this love the last
when they watch the gom films
before we realize this was out we were
going to do a reaction to something that
geoff films did for us which was geo and
film's dubs the real rejects so i was
like all right let's watch the captain
captain america chris have this one
first and then after we're done with
this one
earn this oh yeah let's earn this yeah
because i love gom films work this is
it's
amazing stuff what he does man it takes
a lot of work
ignore the kids outside they're not
having as much fun as we're about
oh let's watch let's watch yes this last
episode
it's gonna be awesome the weather's like
such a personality though
it'd be perfect if you called the hawk
[Music]
all right let's see what it is wait
that's not the hulk
why isn't it him
yes yes i love it sam you captain in the
house
your costume you added more white
overkill it's
it's sweet it's sweet sorry wait who are
you captain america that's right and i
approve this
nice
wait who is this oh look who's back
it's the old man from up
wow he just looks
sam did you uh learn that for me
come on you know what you need to do
john save the people
you're saving them aren't you i knew it
i knew it
wait hold on just a second am i starting
to root
for popeye
[Music]
give you an opportunity and peggy's
niece
not cool uh oh my god i kissed her
oh my god i just remembered sorry peggy
sorry i was uh i was texting and so all
i heard was
the black guy in stars and stripes good
job paying attention
while in prison seriously man
yo i respect that fart
and he still looks like a nerd
no they'll never forget what you did for
this country
surprise
surprise
[Music]
i'm not crying you are captain
america and the winter soldier oh man
they actually did replace me as captain
america
i'm black i'm black i'm black you want
everyone
oh what's that suck now get out of my
face
yes i'm not in your face but yeah
subscribe to general films he's awesome
gee you really have bad breath oh oh
that's it
that's it this isn't great you should
quit
no i don't think so i can do this all
day
that's a checkmate son bye
[Laughter]
is that a real awkward exchange did he
have with someone because it looked like
him
like yeah he looks like he's got kind of
antsy
and she doesn't look like she's entirely
getting what she wants out of it either
i love how yes chris evans was rooting
for sam the whole time but every time
john walker was on screen he still just
kept making fun of him
this is like this nerd over here one two
like you know even it's to get so
specific is like oh the old man from up
is back like you got a [ __ ] like how
long did you look for a clip that would
match that specific piece of dialogue
or did you just get lucky with the dub i
don't know none of this is luck it's all
skill dude it's all skill
dub this all day i love
how he maintains like a character
with this version of chris evans his
personality
goofy giggly chris evans yeah cause if
you watch his other dubs he's
he's not just doing line matching with
the with the lips
he's creating like a certain type of
aura and personality with the character
behind the dub and matching the clips to
that you can feel a strange kind of
character he's developed
with him you know yeah and that's one of
the charming things that kind of helps
with
you know like certain dubs i feel like
there are two camps you know there's
like a dub where it's more about
getting like exactly on the lips and
then there's the other side where it's
more about yeah
crafting whatever the source footage is
into
something greater and so these start to
feel like chris evans has like an
alternate universe youtube channel where
he just cuts these random little videos
up and puts them out there because yeah
i love how you're
cutting around the footage sometimes
which i imagine helps you
bury some of the more complicated you
know dialogue that you're coming up with
but it also lends to the homespun
reaction video quality so like again
this is a really nice little format that
you're working in you killed it man
you killed it dude killed it guys
subscribe to geon films you haven't done
so already we gotta watch this other
video subscribe to the real rejects
click that notification bell hit that
like button
peice
[Music]
you